how did the scientific facts about
carbon and climate shape policy carbon
accumulates let's think about the policy
implication let's compare carbon
emissions to air pollution the other
major impact of energy use as we
discussed earlier air pollution former
energy use has profound worldwide
consequences it kills several million
people a year and shortness the lives of
people in the most polluted cities by
many years yet the air pollution you
breathe depends on the emission of
pollutants only over the last few days
if we could somehow stop admitting all
these pollutants the air would be clean
in weeks climate is not like that
suppose we eliminated all carbon
emissions today temperatures would
continue to slowly increase and only
stabilize about a century from now sea
levels will continue to rise for many
centuries eliminating emissions will
stop the main human force that drives
climate change but it will not make
climate change go away not for a long
time carbon dioxide spreads globally so
the climate impact of one ton of co2
emissions is the same whether it is
admitted in Beijing or Rio de Janeiro
air pollution is more localized summer
air pollutants have impacts over just a
few kilometres others over an entire
continent but collectively air pollution
risks are much more localized than
climate risks these cold scientific
facts have profound consequences for
climate policy this is a big part of the
reason it's so hard for us to get
agreement to cut carbon emissions when a
country incurs a cost to cut air
pollution it usually receives most of
the benefits from the cleaner air and
gets those benefits relatively quickly
contrast this to carbon emissions where
countries may have to incur large cost
to cut emissions and yet the benefits
are spread over the whole world and are
not fully realized for centuries this
difficulty is further compounded by the
fact that it's cheaper to cut air
pollution than carbon and the countries
have different contributions to carbon
emissions over time for example look at
this figure showing current carbon
emissions flow and historical
contributions the carbon stock notice
that the countries with the largest
historical contributions like the United
States
aren't necessarily the same as those
were the largest current emissions like
China both climate and air pollution are
in the language of economists public
goods it's always hard for societies to
coordinate to supply public goods but it
gets harder when the benefits are
further away in space and time and
harder yet when the costs are high and
the responsibilities diffuse